so I don't know where the hell I am I am
all confused I've just lost my job
everything is happening where do you
look when you feel that way the place to
look is not only to your feelings not to
your interpretations or not ask help
from a third person necessarily but ask
yourself what were you in the image what
where's your imagination that
immediately locates you somewhere in
your in the psyche whereas the
introspection doesn't help at all
chasing one's shadow questioning why did
I do this why do I do that
and why did they do this an instant
turmoil the Hindus call it verita
turning the mind on itself like an
anthill but when you have an image of an
anthill you know where you are you're in
the middle of an anthill they're going
in 50 different directions at once but
the ants are doing something it seems
desperate to me only because I say it
shouldn't be an anthill but an anthill
has an internal structure now we're
talking about the muck from last night
an anthill has an internal structure it
is an organization so the gift of an
image is that it affords a place to
watch your soul precisely what it is
doing
of course if instead of the language of
concept the anthill is your confusion
and then you think oh I always get
confused when somebody leaves me I get
confused when I get rejected I don't
know where I am I just walk in a
thousand different directions
see that's an end of interpretation of
the anthill instead of that kind of
language which implies how important you
are it's all about you see it's about me
walking in a thousand different
directions and I don't know who I am and
I'm rejected and I'm lost and so on it's
back to subjectivism and you're not
really talking about the anthill at all
any longer
I've left the image instead of that you
can talk to the confusion to the
confusion in the language of the image
which is an anthill the ants are
swarming some are going up some are
coming down some are carrying eggs
somewhere some are taking care of I
don't know what carrying a dead one
there's a great deal going on if you
begin to imagine an anthill let's see
what the ants are doing and I'm not
thinking about confusion anymore I'm
watching the phenomenon but I said last
night about being interested and seeing
phenomenologically what is happening I'm
no longer caught in my own subjectivity
oh me oh my you know I'm confused I'm
lost I'm I'm going in a thousand
directions instead I'm watching an
imaginative figure I'm fascinated with
what's going on and this attentiveness
is quieting to begin with
it's quieting I can see it
scientifically watch as a naturalist
does the phenomenologist of the psyche
is also a naturalist of the psyche
watching the way it produces what it
produces I might see the ants suddenly
all eating each other up it's no use
saying this is a destructive scene
that's happening I have to wonder about
purposefulness - let's watch maybe the
psyche is taking care of the problem by
itself we don't know in advance we have
to stick with the image stay in the
imagination oh oh they just started
crawling on my feet eating my feet I
can't stand it they're crawling up my
legs I'm going crazy
that's that fear of no now the image is
vividly coming to life still stay with
it what is your reaction I can brush
them off I can run around in circles I
can get a dish of honey to attract them
elsewhere I can sing them an ant song
you see I can do something in
relationship to the actual thing that is
happening but what I don't
won't do is interpret the ants you saw
that move they're crawling up my legs
I'm going crazy that shift from image to
interpretation and that makes you crazy
you see that move when the ants are
crawling up my legs now instead of doing
something brushing them off stepping
aside making a move in the imagination
realm you say I'm going crazy and it's
that move from the image into a thought
that I am that is where the craziness
begins yes the sentence is I'm going
crazy so it could be any of two or three
things but the craziness comes from
losing the image and getting back into
what's happening to me the point is I
don't want to blank it you know and just
blanket out interpretation there are
ways of speaking to the images and with
the images that do favor them and I
think the best way of talking about it
would be does the image like what you're
saying is this really responding
imaginatively to the image it would be
the same thing you do if you go to the
gallery of the museum and you're looking
at some paintings and you look at a
painting and you say my goodness that
reminds that's so much like what soutine
did in this home so does the painting
want to hear that youth comparing it to
soutine's painting of 20 years it
doesn't want to hear that it wants to be
looked at and seen what what what's
there and I think that if if we can talk
to the images so that they like what
we're saying if we say to the image boy
you got some you're knocking me out or
why did you why is there so much green
in here this green is I don't you know
or something so you're responding to
what's there
other than making some kind of
historical comparative conceptual move
this is again the sense that the image
is alive is a person that has
intelligence right has integrity and you
you speak you what you say it has to
appreciate and if we do that with images
we could begin to do that with a lot of
other things such as rooms and animals
and rocks and lots of others and that's
called animism and that's a no-no see
that's a no-no because that's put sold
into places that our religion is said
there isn't any soul or it's called
anthropomorphism what's that it's a
no-no in our orthodoxy oh no I would
think that my personal if that's what
it's called opinion there's already
pretty clear that it's not a no-no
there's a little Pullman that Robert Bly
quotes a lot from the David Ignat talk
something I can I never can remember any
of these things but it's two lines about
about being able to look at a mountain
without thinking what it means to me
well not not as the primary concern
that's not the primary concern of course
you're involved with those ants or
whatever but you're not you're not
after first of all you're not after
meaning again another thing we're hooked
on what does it mean not only
information but meaning when you look at
a painting you don't or a building you
don't ask what does it mean or when you
listen to music you don't ask what does
it mean you listen to the music and the
moment you start asking what does it
mean you're into program program music
or something
so can we move move away from that being
hooked on meaning what does it mean now
this is a difficult one because the
systems of psychology are all give us
meaning and we want meaning for our
lives I don't know what we're after I
let's just stay with what what we tend
to do is is look for meaning in things
and if we can look at the dream without
going after its meaning which is very
difficult because every morning I wake
up with a dream I'm still hooked on
meaning I like I want to and that kills
the dream I the dreams fade the moment I
go at it with us with that net yes
the relationship everything that is said
would you would you want your daughter
to marry an animal that's me
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah that's absolutely right I'm
delighted you said that because the that
that is the other side of the annum it
isn't merely the old Girl Scout code
which is we take care of the poor
suffering imprisoned animals it's
something more than that it's a it's a
philosophical change that we're not the
center of the universe and it's a it's a
beginning of a move away from our human
subjectivism and it's very important
because there isn't a sing you know all
the philosophies that to decide what
animals are from st. Thomas through
that's a whole other chapter but anyway
all the way up to Heidegger no animal
would vote for any of those philosophies
they all declare animals to be senseless
or you know it's a long history so the
change of the sense that that they have
rights is a sharing of with something
non-human it's getting out of our
humanism that's very important in that
sense so it is very similar to paying
attention to the images and I often talk
about images as animals that they have
feet and they walk and they they talk
and they make moves
yes just the last paragraph here the the
interpretive move I'm going crazy
they're crawling up my legs I'm going
crazy the hermeneutic move made the
craziness
who says you are going crazy what you
actually feel is the ants crawling up
your legs then there are other questions
to be put into this scene I mean you
have to locate yourself in it
extend the terrain a bit not a lot not
too much but a bit have you stepped on
the ants have you tried to cross their
path have you put your foot unknowingly
into an anthill
step away it's a certain animal movement
an animal sense of living this is the
active relation to the image that we
want to get going through therapy I
don't want to stand here with these ants
on my on my legs how did how did that
happen I so I make it an animal move of
some kind rather than necessarily an
interpretive move